so 28 year old Jake how many
championships 28 year old day like that
I'm not gonna drinks myself but six
years I'm gonna go ahead and say five or
six I'm gonna say that so you win in the
championship every year from here until
yeah you already did you already said it
and I don't play to lose so I'm gonna go
ahead and say I'm gonna go I'm gonna
give it a five
five rings by 28.
that's what I enjoyed that yeah how
confident are you about winning this
year
like people misconstrue confidence and
arrogance you know I mean I'm not being
arrogant and you're gonna have to take
the steps to be a team that we say we
want to be right because we got the
mindset of a champion I think that's
where it starts